we're going to do what ben wants to do
and how ben wants to do it our job is
putting every player in position to make
plays so there are changes with
um terminology how we're calling things
which has been adjusted for ben and he's
been great and really learning it doing
really well with it and i think he you
know this has adapted you know easily
it's like we all know that he would but
you know the answer to your question
that is our job
matchups are how you win football games
ben starts with the quarterback what
does he do well what does he like what
does he see
what is good his eye
in the passing game and then we build
off that
matt canada
the new offensive coordinator of the
pittsburgh steelers randy fickner out
matt canada in with some pretty clear
directives on what he needs to do or it
will be
blame canada
are you yeah i am
yeah no you're not an old-timer for that
that's that's south park is that south
park is that right that was the movie
oh that was the movie no not team
america world police it was a south park
movie i thought bigger louder and uncut
right they actually well there's shows
on call from yeah
i recall the academy awards
the year after that movie came out they
did a whole blame canada production with
robin williams i think check it out on
youtube kids but not now wait until the
show's over but i think robin williams
sang blame canada with like you know
thousands of performers to open or some
at some point during the office
i vaguely remember i'll check that out
old timer okay i'll check it out that's
not that long ago that's in the last 20
years i remember it so i can't say it's
that old yes i remember it
so uh canada said among other things
yesterday that mr rooney and look
in in in kind of a low-key but not
really way
art rooney runs that freaking team he he
he calls the shots baby if somebody's
getting fired he's making the decision
defensive coordinator offensive
coordinator that's that's rooney's the
man rooney's the man in the draft room
they made that clear before the draft
this year art rooney runs that team and
art rooney told matt canada clear
directive we have to be able to run the
ball this year and as jerome bettis told
ed bouchette last season i've mentioned
it several times because it rung true
with me it's a commitment that has to
begin
as early as possible definitely and it
has to be adhered to
all year long you can't deviate you
can't waiver you can't have a
quarterback who's changing out the play
because he wants to throw a four-yard
pass you've got to establish yourself as
brutes you can't have those guys going
backward even out on that play what kind
of blocking is that i know it's a draw
play yeah but you want to see the guys
firing off the ball you don't want to
see him going back you want to see him
going forward it's a fun fundamentally
different skill set you want guys
bashing the opposing player
in the face with a legal hit of course
yeah but you want to you want to see
overpowering with brute physical force
yeah no you don't see any of that i mean
should look at the clips we show here
there's free people every time there's
missed blocks there's no movement on the
line of scrimmage none of the clips we
just showed what four running plays in a
row we never saw the defense go backward
in any of them and you know to what you
said you're exactly right it is an
attitude that starts really as early as
possible but mainly it's going to start
in training camp and any team that i was
ever on that was a good running football
team that's really what it was about it
was like hey that first day of training
camp you know yeah we're not in pads but
we're gonna have this is gonna be our
bread and butter these running plays
we're gonna be good at these five
running plays that's what we know and it
starts there and then that first day you
put on the pads you start to realize
like whoa there's a real emphasis we've
run 96 power king you know
six out of 15 plays in a team period and
you know the other nine plays out of
those five of them were runs so yes it
is about that attitude and they lost
their way last year with attitude you
know always being in pass sets it's hard
to create that when you're like this 50
times a game and you're never really
firing off or getting to assert yourself
that way so that's where it starts mr
rooney hey it's the family business he
knows what wins football games he sees
that damn defense he's got right mike
and that's where it makes no sense with
the way they played last year you know
you you talk about you know team
football complementary football for that
defense they have there
it makes no sense to be a high octane
we're going to throw the ball 50 times a
game type of type of offense
and
of all years the offensive line seems
experimental at best yeah this year
especially with marquis penalty retired
new center how big of a deal is that
though when you're when you're trying
to improve on the stuff that we saw in
those clips of some bad blocking and
some lack of commitment to the run how
much harder is it to do that
when you're going through these changes
and it's not just marquis pouncey matt
filer's gone he went to the chargers
alejandro villanueva he was a free agent
they showed no interest in bringing him
back but pouncey's the key here
uh
what's the biggest challenge when you've
got a quarterback who's pushing 40 who's
got to deal with his first new center
in over a decade well i think the first
thing is like you know continuity is the
biggest thing so yeah it's going to be
new guys but like we saw last year i
think one of the huge things that hurt
them is is of course the injuries it was
a big part of it you know the fact that
they kind of had to move around people
and do that type of stuff i think that
was a little bit of why they morph into
this like wait this guy's not used to
pulling or blocking down and doing this
and doing some of these run game things
so let's just err on hey let's pass and
let ben figure it out i think that was
the start of it so that would be the big
thing to me is just the continuity
between the five and yeah you got a
little bit of some unproven commodities
on their roster to a degree does the
rookie they drafted you know from
illinois in the third or fourth round
does he play and do that he's certainly
nfl ready uh but to me that's really
where it stands again is just getting
that base of attitude here's our core
plays and let's find the right
mix of the five to where everybody it's
our best five and they're all playing in
a position they're comfortable and then
you can really build something off a run
game and you can start to run plays
where you go the defense knows what
we're running and they still can't stop
it and that's the good running teams
i've been been a part of
yeah kendrick green one of the options
bj finney jc haasenauer and
also floating around on the depth chart
for the steelers but they got to get
that figured out and and they're they're
hoping they're projecting they're
they're
choosing to view the glass as half full
but it may end up being half empty and
if that offensive line doesn't get it
done now maybe naji harris is good
enough that he's going to get his yards
even without blocking but
it's not like he did it without blocking
at alabama no no but he is between the
tackles runner he can make people miss
in short areas and do that and he has
real size like you know he was a tough
eval for me he was not my favorite
because i yeah i guess lack of speed and
things like that concerned me um but
you know the steelers attitude something
they like and he does bring a physical
element to their team to what we're
talking about to where they're listening
to mr rooney and you know to everything
you're saying too with like you know the
glass half full approach and all those
things i think they look at it like
we've talked about a lot that if they
can do some of those things big ben will
look a lot better than what he was
towards the end of last year too because
it'll take some pressure off of him
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports